Warfarin. Warfarin is an anticoagulant that acts by binding and
inhibiting a protein called VKORC1. Now
VKORC1 normally helps recycle vitamin
K. It takes it from its epoxidized form. To its reduced
form. Now it may not sound like much, it's still vitamin K. There is a chemical
change going on here, but that's a huge difference in allowing a certain kind
of vitamin K to promote blood clotting.
VKORC1 recycles this vitamin K and promotes the
production of a reduced vitamin K that
promotes blood clotting. Now, warfarin's an anti-coagulant,
or something that inhibits blood clotting. Because
it actually blocks the activity of VKORC1. If
you block VKORC1, then you can't get the epoxidized form
of vitamin k back to the reduced form. So you don't
get as much blood clotting. You inhibited blood clotting. Now,
most of us realize that blood clotting in a good thing.
Especially when you hurt yourself. When you get an injury
on your skin, and your, your blood starts spilling out, you
want it to stop spilling out, so it clots, and
that's a good thing. But sometimes blood clotting can happen inside
your blood vessels, inside your arteries. And anytime that happens
it could be really bad, because we're going to block the
flow of blood in your body. So if you have
an overactive blood clotting system, you might be at more
risk of blocking vessels. And if you have an under-active
blood clotting system, you may not have enough clotting when
you need it when you get injured. Now the efficacy
of Warfarin, or its effectiveness, is measured by how well
it inhibits this overall vitamin K recycling. A measure
of how effective it is at inhibiting VKORC1. So which
of the following would result in an increase or higher
efficacy of warfarin? Strong inhibition of VKORC1 or weak inhibition?